Spending Habits.
Today I went to the mall with my Mom and my baby sister.
My Mom totally embarrassed me by yelling at me in public!
I mean, people were watching!
My sister got scared and started crying.
But Mom didn't stop screaming about my spending habits.
I don't get it.
Once she gives me allowance, doesn't that become my money?
Why does she care what I spend it on?
I don't criticize her shopping habits!
Mom was saying stuff like,...
..."I'm telling you to stay at home from now on."
"You're not allowed to go out with your friends anymore!"
"You're grounded."
She said until I turn 18,...
...the money she gives me is still her money...
...and she has the right to tell me what to buy or what not to buy...
...with that money.
So, I have to wait...
...two more years until I can spend my own money on what I want.
I'm thinking of getting a job.
I can work at the coffee house in my neighborhood.
I also saw the "Now Hiring" sign at the chicken place...
...near the mall.
I mean,...
...I'll do anything to make money on my own so that...
...Mom doesn't nag anymore.
I understand her nagging at home,...
...but in public places? Give me a break!
Parents can be so embarrassing sometimes.